DR JAMES GRIME: So today, I want
to tell you that almost
all integers contain
the digit 3.
So the integers are
the whole numbers.
So I'm saying that almost
all whole numbers
contain the digit 3.
It sounds strange, doesn't it?
Yeah, because I can think of
infinitely many numbers that
contain a 3.
I've got 3, 33, 333,
3,333, and so on.
I can think of infinitely
many numbers that
don't contain a 3.
7, 77, 777, and 7,777,
and so on.
So how can almost all integers
contain the digit 3?
So 23 contains the digit 3.
310 contains the digit 3.
9,002,023.
So what about the numbers
less than 10?
How many numbers less than
10 contain the digit 3?
It's just 3, isn't it?
Yeah, it's just one of them.
Right.
So one of those, just
the number 3 itself.
So what's the proportion
of numbers?
Well, it's one out of ten.
So it's 1/10.
It's 0.1.
It's 10%.
What's the next size up?
Let's look at numbers
less than 100.
We've got 3.
We've got 13, 23, 43,
53, 63, 73, 83, 93.
You may have noticed I skipped
off the 30s there.
So we've got 30, 31,
32, 33, 34, 35--
so I reckon we've got 19.
19 out of 100, that's 0.19.
It's 19% is what I'm saying.
So the percentage has gone up.
Let's try numbers
less than 1,000.
Well, we've got the 19 we
said already, right?
But we've got all those
numbers again,
but with a 1 in front.
Like it's 103 and 113 and then
we get 200 and something.
We get 400 and something,
500, 600, 700, 800, 900.
And then we can include
all the 300s,
which I skipped there.
So just the 300, 301,
302, 303, right?
So it's 271.
What's the percentage?
It's about 0.271--
27%.
It's going up.
Now, did you notice the
trick that we used
for that last one?
I said, think of all the numbers
with a 1 in the front.
It was the same copy but with a
1 in the front, with a 2 in
the front, and then it
was all the 300s.
You can do this in general.
The numbers containing a digit
3-- let's call that T for 3.
Let's call these 10.
Less than 10 to the power n.
So these are the numbers
containing a digit 3, less
than 10 to the power n.
If you want to find
the next one-- and
that's going to be 10,000.
You take the last of your
previous number, times it by
9, and add on 10
to the power n.
And you can find the
next number.
You can do that.
So that would be the next
one we're looking for.
So there's a little
formula there.
So let's do it.
All right then, I'm going
to use my calculator.
So 9 times 271, plus 1,000.
And I get that number, 3,439.
What's the proportion?
It's about 0.3439.
It's going up all the time--
about 34% now.
It's going up all the time.
In fact, there's a nice way to
work out how many numbers
there're going to be with a 3.
Imagine if I was allowed to
write my numbers like this,
with zeroes.
So that would be a zero, but
with all these zeroes there.
This is a four-digit number.
So here's another one, and
here's another one.
How many four-digit
numbers are there?
It's actually 10
to the power 4.
10 choices there, 10 choices
there, 10 choices, 10 choices.
How many of them
don't have a 3?
Well, if I'm not allowed to use
3, then I only have nine
choices for that place, nine
choices for that place.
So that would be 9
to the power 4.
If you want to find out how many
integers that contain the
digit 3, it is 10 to the power
n, minus 9 to the power n.
See, these are all my n-digit
numbers minus the ones that
don't contain a 3.
The proportion, then, is going
to be this thing divided by
this thing--
just 10 to the n.
So it's this.
And what is that proportion?
10 to the n divided by 10 to the
n is 1, minus 9 to the n
divided by 10 to the n.
Here's another way
to write that--
9/10 to the n.
That's the proportion that
contain a digit 3.
And just what happens?
Well, as this gets really,
really big, this fraction gets
smaller and smaller
and smaller.
And it will go to 1.
That will disappear.
It will barely be worth
mentioning.
And that is 1.
So it goes to 1--
we say, as n gets big.
So this is getting closer
and closer to 1 minus 0.
As that gets closer to 0, as it
gets big, this gets closer
and closer to 1 minus 0.
So the whole thing is
going towards 100%.
100% of numbers contain
the digit 3.
And this is the proper technical
definition of when I
said almost all numbers
contain the digit 3.
"Almost all" sounds like a
wishy-washy vague expression.
But in mathematics, it
has a proper meaning.
It means that the proportion
is going toward 100% as you
get more and more numbers.
BRADY HALAN: Would it be equally
true to say almost all
numbers contain the number 5?
DR JAMES GRIME: That would
be equally true.
And you can do the exact same
thing to say almost all
numbers contain a 5.